all right here's the last one that I'm
going to tackle in this series of
different problems that are all related
to now I don't think it's pretty
shocking
um it's Pythagoras's Theorem okay and
it's a really Charming Problem by the
way I encourage you to actually give
this a well get a piece of paper and you
can see that you can create with an 8x12
piece of paper folded such that from
this corner down here right if it's just
a regular old right angled uh let's
actually
okay I'll do it this way let's do it in
pencil shall we if I kind of Imagine
going down this way here is the original
piece of paper the right angle there
right and what I've done is I've folded
from here up into this corner so you can
see if I were to add it in there maybe a
different color you can see this corner
goes all the way up into here what you
want to do is find where the midpoint of
this uh longer side is and then the
question is what is the length of this
fold what is
this length in here okay
there you go sorry it's not very neat
all right now Charming question I hope
you don't mind that what I've done is
I've prepared earlier a diagram a more
like a non picture of a piece of paper
diagram that we're going to be able to
do all of our construction is on so I
hope you can see it's basically the same
thing right here's the original piece of
paper and then what you've got in
outline here is again imagine drawing
this same kind of um uh going from the
corner and drawing it up into there or
folding it rather up into there and
we're going to try and find out what
this uh this length here is going to be
okay and so since that's the unknown I'm
going to call that X and I better get
this Blue Fold Arrow out of the way
because it's going to Cloud our diagram
very briefly
so what's the length of this fold what I
want to start doing is assembling the
information that I know and then trying
to find what x is by relating all this
piece of information together
so the first thing I note is that it's
an 8 by 12 piece of paper so this is the
shorter length over here so I guess that
must be eight and this entire length
across the top is 12 but I know that
this point up here that I was folding up
to is the midpoint of an edge which
tells me that this is six now what I
want to do then is say how can I get
this 6 and this eight and relate them to
the X right
well for starters um because I've sort
of gotten in the in the rhythm of things
already I know that there are going to
be some right angle triangles um here
and some of them are very easy to spot
right so for example I've obviously got
a right angle triangle happening up in
this top left hand corner
um however
um even though it's sort of promising to
be able to get from this six into this
hypotenuse to then get toward the X
um I don't know this other length over
here so I guess I could say well maybe
we call this
um I don't know what's happening with
the proportions of this fold up here
because it's another unknown I guess
I'll maybe I'll call this a and that
means because uh this whole vertical
length here is eight then this lower
length here is going to be the
difference right so this is going to be
eight take away a so this goes this far
and then this one goes this far okay so
far so good now what this tells me is if
I have a look and I'm gonna I'm gonna
cheat and grab that triangle that I drew
before because it because I'm lazy
um and it's already been done there we
go all the way back to this question
let's let's grab this one
so if I go all the way here we are
and pop this in
let's whoa where did it go
try it again ta-da let's put that there
and now if I move that up okay excellent
I've got a right angle triangle here
right
and allows me to work out the hypotenuse
here which is going to be a good step in
the right direction because you can see
that as I sort of work out more about
this triangle here in the middle it's
going to be able to help me get towards
this x Okay so
what can I do here well I noticed that
um because I can just say using you know
right angle triangles this is going to
be the square root of
um a squared plus 36. so I know I'm
doing a little bit in my head here but
all this comes from is a squared plus 6
squared equals this hypotenuse squared
so if I were to take the square root and
then simplify that 6 squared this is
what you would get okay
so this is good one of the things that I
notice as well is this is not the only
right angle triangle which I can create
which helps me get to like information
about this bigger triangle here right
now you can see I've got this length
over here and if I sort of lean in from
the right hand side of the rectangle
here so if I were to create let's do it
this way
a vertical line here
I know
that this length here is going to be
eight as well because I just drew it
parallel it's vertical
what I've got over here is let's
duplicate this I've got another right
angle triangle here like so
let's make this one a different color
the filling as well
there we go so this triangle here is
also right angled because remember I
sort of Drew this line by just going
straight vertically up okay but I'm I
can get some information about this
triangle here and this triangle here
because if you look closely there's
actually a very important relationship
between these two triangles I wonder if
you can spot it
think for a moment with me remember this
was created this whole diagram was
created by taking this rectangular piece
of paper so it's got right angles at all
of its corners and then folding it up to
here right so if there was a right angle
here originally then there is still a
right angle in this piece of paper at
the corner when it's in a different
place right so there's a right angled
triangle in the middle here created here
in this corner so if I say hey look
there's a there's a there's a right
angle there
if I name this angle Theta in here what
that tells me is if I have a look at
these three angles on this straight line
right theta plus 90 over here what does
this angle have to be to make these
angles add up to 180 and hopefully you
can determine pretty quickly that's
going to be the complement of 90. it'll
be 90 minus Theta in this corner here
now because I've got this angle I've
also got a right angle that tells you
down in the corner that this is also
going to be Theta right so this is
brilliant because what I've got now is
I've got two triangles the blue and the
green one which they're both right
angled they both have a theater in them
so these are in fact similar to each
other they're going to be equally
angular as soon as you've got two angles
being equal to each other obviously the
third angle must also be equal so if you
wanted you could put the complement of
theta over here as well but we don't
need to we've got a Theta and a Theta
here right
so therefore let's just sort of bring
these together
um in a sort of separate little diagram
over here if I duplicate that one and I
know it'll be a little easier to see if
we get them in the same
orientation and by the way this is a
trick that I use all the time when I'm
trying to line up similar triangles with
each other and and look at where their
features are that are in ratio with each
other so you can see
I've got a 6 a triangle here and then if
you compare that to this triangle over
here the green one the taller one right
you might recall that uh this length
over here is the one that's rotated to
become this length over here so this is
eight and to confirm that you can see
that the Theta which is here in the
corner is also the Theta jammed between
the eight and also the hypotenuse in
this original triangle right before I
rotated it anyway
so therefore if you have a look right uh
using the ratios the thing that is going
to be valuable here about right angled
sorry about similar triangles is that uh
corresponding sides are in proportion so
can you see that going from here to here
what we're doing is we are multiplying
by four over three this is a third times
longer than the other side so therefore
I can do the same thing with this other
length over here right I'm just going to
multiply by four over three that's what
it means for the sides to be the
corresponding sides rather to be in the
same proportion so four thirds time a
times a is just four thirds a right